Christmas season and I know I want to
talk to you about Christmas parties
because you've been known to have some
legendary legendary Christmas party yes
not just where there's like no people
come over and we sing a few carols and
here have a cookie we Jam you Jam this
yeah because you were a fine musician
and you get other musicians yes famous
people the best like who's that guys who
have and men and women who have you know
and have been on your show the same kind
of thing but III haven't had a party in
like three years but I used to have
these giant holiday parties and
everybody would come and jam and all the
greatest musicians would come by and
claim we would Jam for like three and a
half hours and then I you Smyly your
Frank smile I smile Easter on the show
since the very beginning and one of the
nicest humans and he's nice to you yell
at him he said who was an interesting
guy that jammed and anything funny
happened with any of the musicians and
I'm sure they were a bunch but I do the
first one that came to mind gene Simmons
gene Simmons from kiss from kiss yeah so
I have a party all these great musicians
Jam all like 2,000 people show up
everyone's go nuts as people I work with
or have worked with their their friends
whatever lots of people everyone's going
to us
gene Simmons when we're onstage playing
a kiss tune pulls out the tongue the
tongue comes out seven inch or a seven
picture and it starts coming at the
Sandman with the tongue and I'm like
playing along and then I'm like oh man
he's getting real close he's coming in
ah yeah yeah came at the same a big
tongue right to me I think he gave me a
couple of licks now do you are you able
to are you able to relax at one of your
own parties can you have a good time and
relax it's pathetic my parties was so
great for everybody I would always hear
like the next week like awesome and I
was in creative boom and we there was
the best best orgy I've ever been a part
of
to do it to do that much acid and then
I'm end up in an orgy yeah thanks Jim
Simmons lick me on acid incredible but
I'm like everyone has the best time at
all and they're like how about you Jamie
and then I'm like I seriously everyone I
had about 20 of them all I thought about
was like that party cost me probably
eight hundred grand and I would go
around body at the end of the night to
say to anybody they're just like you
want to kick in for this and everyone's
I know you've been to my you but you
come to my Christmas parties you're the
baddest no there's no jamming but
there's a lot fun the best food by the
way that's good food good ham go Turkey
well I'm Irish Catholic so yeah my
culture the way you celebrate Christmas
is you literally hang hams on ropes from
the ceiling and everyone bats at them it
takes big big chomps I mean well we all
guy have heart attacks at like 30 it is
crazy good though you him every year I
get so excited I walk there because I
live near the cone man yeah walk over
there eat my hand my wife says calm down
with the ham you're having too much ham
you got you get moody rude for you to
say you come to my house for the ham I
why don't you say you come to see me
like I gotta get that hand I got the ham
we can go now you're there all the time
there one thing you're right anyways no
it's a fun it's usually a for last party
we were at Coney gets loose at these I
got a little loose sometimes I see he'll
he'll hit it hard and he gets a he gets
in a good mood jolly mood and as we all
have fun and but last year in particular
Coney was a little saucy oh yes a little
Oh crazy talk I was just ruin a relaxed
state of mind okay yeah you didn't see
that I put a giant ham in my pocket
[Laughter]
but Cody was lettin Tom Hanks have it so
bad because everyone's so he's such a
nice guy and everyone treats him like a
legend I thought this is [ __ ]
someone should like go after him so I
decided this is the night that Hanks
gets there's Tom Hanks a new [ __ ] cuz
no one could believe what I saw
yeah Kony screaming thanks Tony
that guy's had a free ride way too long